air marshal philip osborne is a former
chief of defense intelligence and
director at universal defense and
security solutions he's here with me now
good morning marshall good morning um
mr zielanski and his people um
just heard there
want the introduction of a no-fly zone
and that's been
resisted and we understand the formal
reasons but
do you think that's
going to be true forever
i guess it depends
where the west wants to end up excuse me
militarily you can put in place in
no-fly zone um it's complex
it's
dangerous uh has a risk associated with
it militarily
um but the issue i think is less than
military reasons and much more
um the consequences
um
a while ago i've been involved in
policing no-fly zones and and the
critical issue is you have to enforce
them what that means is not just
threatening and sometimes shooting down
opposition aircraft
it means targeting air defense systems
that are trying to stop you operating in
the no-fly zone
in this context it would mean we'd have
to be willing to attack
russian perhaps belarusian forces
not just in ukraine but perhaps in
budarus and perhaps in russia
so
that that risk of escalation
significant escalation and the quite
clear path to further conflict is
something that the west has got to be
comfortable with has got to be ready for
if it implements a no-fly zone
do you think that the intelligence
assessment that the politicians will be
getting now would be saying
you could do that
but in truth rather than
uh
creating a situation in which the
russians and belarusians can back off
it would be on balance
uh
a provocation to for them to step up uh
their firepower
i think we have to perhaps take a step
back here
um
putin's in a hole he's in a corner
um
he's
he's personalized the conflict in
ukraine
um and therefore that brings with it all
kinds of risks his options are
not nearly as clear as they were at the
start of this conflict you know only 11
days ago
but also at home he really needs to
maintain a narrative maintain a
um a rationale
which is where he's going at the moment
which is this is counter nato
this is this is to stop nato
expansionism this is all about the
security of russia
um
part of the implementation of the no-fly
zone gives him that opportunity to
underline that narrative at home to make
this about nato and russia not about his
miscalculation in ukraine
so i think
it is the
the options it gives him
to
step up into what he wants to be saying
um that is a real risk that the
the western governments will be thinking
about and being being advised on
okay well let's suppose that doesn't
happen
things
proceed pretty much as they are now
do you think he's told um president
macron in a phone call last week
that he wants to control the whole of
ukraine um
how realistic is that given the size
of that territory four times the size of
england i think um i i think there's two
things there there's the size of the
territory we'll come back to that but
there's 40 million people that don't
want him there and they're showing every
day with
remarkable resistance bravery
um
stoicism
that
he just can't hold that country i think
any nation
who thinks it's going to hold a country
of 40 million plus people who just don't
want you there regardless of the size as
killing themselves
so he may be saying that
[Music]
taking over ukraine removing it as a
supposed threat to to russia is his end
state i just can't see him being advised
even by those yes men there's around him
that that's possible
and therefore
he must be looking for
some kind of way out perhaps partition
which allows him to shift the narrative
to say hey look you know i've achieved
what i wanted to achieve
but i think we come back to he's in a
corner this is not where he planned to
be he planned to have a puppet regime in
place on day two i mean one of the other
reasons that perhaps things haven't
panned out in a way that um he might
have expected
is that um
as many analysts have said they're
rather surprised at what seems to be the
poor performance of russian forces um
has he got a white elephant on his hands
he spent a lot of money
um bringing those armed forces up to
scratch but they don't seem to be doing
what he wants
um at the heart of military power is is
people
it's have you got the right people with
the right morale the right training
and
the right skills to do the type of
things he's trying to do so yes you're
right there's a lot of expensive
equipment and a lot of it is stuck in
muddy ditches
in ukraine at the moment
if we take a step back again i think
what we're seeing is a hugely
overconfident russian military
engaging with the reality of a really
high-end well-equipped highly motivated
opponent
so so i think we've seen an error of
overconfidence as far as they're
concerned and they have underestimated
the ukrainians
that's led to
tactical and operational level failures
in terms of logistics
in terms of command and control
but
but what i think is also underlined is
that russia's just not used to doing
this type of stuff
big coordinated air land maritime
operations on many axes
are really difficult and nations like
the uk the us and others
train really hard to make
to ensure you've got that capability
russia's not been doing that
is uh
one consequence of
him being as you put it in a hole
that he simply just has to get as it
were a bigger cudgel i.e
uh
more firepower
shelling of civilian targets for example
um
we're already there
i mean what we're seeing is
is the chechnya is the syria playbook um
he was trying to be fast he was trying
to be
manipulative of public opinion you know
puppet regime perhaps in two or three
days that's clearly not worked um his
forces are proving that they're not
nearly as agile as they thought they
were going to be
and therefore what we're seeing
um
tragically is russia doing what russia
normally does which is when it's in a
whole applies violence extreme violence
um
to break civilian morale i think
personally in the ukrainians they pick
the wrong opponent and when we say
extreme violence how extreme you know
what i'm really asking here
what is he prepared to use
um
in terms of in ukraine he'll be prepared
to use cluster weapons he's already seen
those
he'll be prepared to use the barbaric
weapons we've seen those deployed
to go further than that again is to risk
a
highly significant escalation
which
even those deluded individuals around
putin um i think would be advising him
against um this is a this is a
multi-level conflict
and
actions at the tactical and operational
level do have strategic impact
it's a dangerous time and he'll
recognize it's a dangerous time
so i would assess
at this stage
weapons beyond those conventional
weapons of mass destruction that i've
just mentioned i can't see those being
used within ukraine in a tactical
context
hey marshall phil osborne thank you so
much thank you